when you think about evolving through
rounds of complexity can you maybe
elaborate such a beautiful phrase
beautiful thought that there's layers of
complexity that make so so with software
sometimes you're like oh let's like
build version two from scratch
but this doesn't happen in evolution in
evolution you layer in additional
features on top of old features so
basically when uh like every single time
my cells divide
I'm a yeast like I'm a unicellular
organism and then cell division is
basically identical
every time I breathe in and my lungs
expand
I'm basically you know like every time
my heart beats I'm a fish so basically
that I still have the same heart like
very very little has changed the blood
going through my veins the oxygen the
you know our immune system we're
basically primates our social behavior
we're basically New World monkeys and
all World monkeys we're basically
um this this concept that every single
one of these behaviors can be traced
somewhere in evolution and that all of
that continues to live within us is also
a testament to not just not killing
other humans for God's sake but like not
killing other species either like just
to realize just how united we are with
nature and that all of these biological
processes have never ceased to exist
they're continuing to live within us and
then just the new cortex and all of the
reasoning capabilities of humans are
built on top of all of these other
species that continue to live breathe
divide metabolize
fight off pathogens all continued inside
us so you think the neocortex the
whatever reasoning is that's the the
latest feature in the in the latest
version of this journey it's it's
extraordinary that humans have evolved
so much in so little time
again if you look at the the timeline of
evolution you basically have billions of
years to even get to a dividing cell and
then a multicellular organism and then a
complex body plan and then these
incredible senses that we have for
perceiving the world the fact that bats
can fly and they evolved flight the
evolved sonar in the span of a few
million years I mean it's just the
extraordinary how much Evolution has
kind of sped up
and all of that comes through this
evolvability the fact that we took a
while to get good at evolving and then
once you get good at evolving you can
sort of
you have modularity built in you have
hierarchical organizations built in you
have all of these constructs that allow
meaningful changes to occur without
breaking the system completely if you
look at a traditional genetic algorithm
the way that humans designed them in the
60s you can only evolve so much and as
you evolve a certain amount of
complexity the number of mutations that
move you away from something functional
exponentially increases and the number
of mutations that move you to something
better exponentially decreases so the
probability of evolving something so
complex becomes infinitesimally small as
you get more complex but with Evolution
it's almost the opposite almost the
exact opposite that it appears that it's
speeding up exactly as complex
complexity is increasing
and I think that's just the system
getting good at evolving